we got your face
hello everybody welcome to episode 2 76
76 special episode we're going to be
talking about terminator genisys woman
in gold Maggie 71 me Earl and the dying
girl in the dying girl absolutely and
we've got a very special guest but also
i'm actually really surprised you had a
flight delay that you're actually in the
garage you had a slight delay him right
from LA I'm right from my eggs and made
it here the exact same time as the
guests only a couple minutes later I was
pulling up while he was coming through
the gate yes and I was like I almost
killed him cuz I didn't recognize my I
just thought there was a foreigner
runnin onya on American soil uh actually
I I forgot which house it was and I
technically went into your neighbor's
yard for this they also have a
drawstring that I breeze their backyard
no I wasn't any different a drawstring I
don't remember that from last time and
then I was like wow chris is Paul seems
to be bigger he didn't have last time I
came here I was like I want as a good
view from this backyard Oh of that [ __ ]
that I meant to value that's it I wonder
why what what kind of podcasts were they
doing a really successful one and
they're selling twice as much much for
this ruling adventure everything yeah
literally hundreds of orders a day how
they can afford that we will always get
trumped like they're drilling a vendre I
went to their your neighbors podcast for
the good merch and rest night will let
those film nerd idiots weirdly enough
okay kiss considering we're talking
about tonight or today it's actually
just you guys in a different timeline
yeah you are just twice as successful as
you are doing exactly the same things
but was successful but making actual
crab meat in that time some kind of
butterfly effect weird thing we gotta go
back in time and kill a butterfly's I
tell you what it was I believe it was
the fog at the san francisco airport
this morning that has that has the fog
at SFO has delayed more flights than
anything did you find yourself on an
aircraft carrier yeah or two but it was
weird i don't know what that martin
sheen is there none of it made sense and
then i saw me
he was older there's this weird guy in a
limo that we never met till the end Wow
I was crazy if it's every time at that
Airport it does seem like they would
come up with some sort of defaulting
technology based on the fact that they
so often you know it's weird don't you
think that no one's working on that no I
imagine all right why is no one in la
working on drains right yeah what yeah
it makes perfect sense what did he build
it they're like let's find the foggiest
part of the peninsula in this Bay and
then let's make let's keep expanding
this Airport I know the Oakland airports
better and it's easier but let's really
Chuck and pump the money into SFO all
right but I made it I literally came
right from the airport I was great today
even on the 405 you made it to full of
horrendous traffic with me I got picked
up probably a little bit before for so
took me an hour and a half in traffic
Wow on top of two flights but turns out
the machines may not have wanted you to
get here now that's what this is all
about Skynet's going online first thing
we can do black gram from podcasting
priority one that's not logic it's just
a stopper and there's delay the podcast
actually now that you think about that I
don't that would want to stop podcasting
because if you really think about the
idea of us being loaded into the
machines the one thing that machines
need I still rake reycarts well you know
he's the guy who's done all the yeah he
works at Google he's like the head
dreamer or whatever at Google he's
valleys write the book about the
singularity right and and his whole
thing is that humor is the trickiest
thing for a I to replicate and that will
know truly that we've got you know
singularity when yo machines have a
sense of humor so surely the thing that
there you would be working on if you are
an artificial like where do you have
access to all these personalities and
all this information about these people
in their lives and be able to process
it's podcast so there's gonna be a
podcast robot all the terminators of the
future will be have the personality of
various podcast they'll just be like
like a corolla bot and the kevin smith
unlike the barren bog maronite up right
before they laser your head off I'm just
gonna be like hashtag work it jodhpurs
what's that Terminator whistling that's
weird why is it was faint impression do
not forget to donate I have a new
Kickstarter no you don't um well if you
haven't figured it out folks uh that is
the voice of Will Anderson hello could I
thank you thank you thank you for Aussie
it up and calling us mate yeah um so
what were you you meant we haven't
talked in a while what have you been up
to your kind of going back and forth
between you do it so I mean yeah okay so
I what the other city you live in like
Los Angeles we need to put it down for
the movie yeah Sydney Sydney okay so I
have a house in sydney that i spent two
weeks in in the last two years yeah so
that's yeah that's a really fight
investment a lot of other people I get a
lot of photos from my friends enjoying
that house keys I work on the road well
love the heart if we turn on the guest
hate it for the pool but seventy five
dollars a day but I guess you guys have
gone better better get on the road so
hilarities in cleveland to pay that
mortgage for you guys better move some
well we'll illuminati spoken cds or
whatever to pay for that essentially the
plot of my life is the plot from weekend
at Bernie's except instead of me being
dead Bernie's on the road in the States
so but yeah so I did 20 US cities last
year and Chris and I were actually just
talking while we were eating pizza just
before you arrived about the fact that I
20 US cities last year and I may be
rounding it up but let's say it this is
it for the sake of the story I believe
in every single one of those cities in
like when would I did a week of shows
there I'd be doing five to seven shows a
week I would have at least one comedy
film nerds fan come up to me in every
single one of those cities as I hello
that's so great amazing right I you know
I guys I love hearing that I love
hearing that you guys go
out and support the stead that that the
guests in comics that are on the show I
love that you're never gonna be
disappointed now yeah we're we're
literally gonna have every reason was it
what didn't say g'nite it move your arms
around and have weird thing that Graham
does you didn't come out in the pouch of
a kangaroo oh great that's my one nods
and my heritage you didn't have a
didgeridoo over yeah yeah self-signed
boomerangs after the show ladies and
gentlemen will anderson oh that would be
the greatest like get the crowd all
pumped up and then that or just do my
act through a didgeridoo have in the end
like is this thing on is the god i love
that alright so i go so i did that ok so
what kind of went on the road in the US
which was brilliant fun and then i went
home at the end of the year because i
was doing my of illuminati show so we
filmed that and you had to kick the
people out of your poor right exactly
what i was when i got literally one of
the two weeks i've heard back there so i
had a week in sydney and I was lucky
enough it during that week to to be
involved in two things the radio station
I used to work at triple j which is the
national youth broadcaster in Australia
was having a 40 year celebration things
I was lucky enough i went back and did a
shift on radio with this guy that i
worked with for like six years who have
not you know worked with in a radius in
our old radio station era it was very
that was a fun thing to do but i also on
that very day January nineteenth filmed
illuminati at the sydney opera house in
in their main work in the in the big
concert hall the biggest yeah it's the
kind of the biggest yeah as an
australian performer there are bigger
rooms but there is no bigger room what
is like let's not just as an australian
performer I mean to play at your house
is pretty amazing that's like that i
mean that's like one of those vent
that's like Carnegie Hall yeah
to world what known world yeah yeah so
we filmed most in my special day so we
did two shows way just in a night and
you know back-to-back and and film both
those and like release that as a DVD
which people can buy in some countries
at the moment and what as I say to
everybody else you can't bite in your
country if you can't abide in your
country steal it I don't mind I honestly
don't like people to see it and if it's
not available in your country then like
I just like you to be able to see it no
problem for me pass it around send it to
somebody whatever if it's in a place
where you can buy it buy it so I can
make more of them but you know what
region is it yeah why but you can
download this itunes downloads and
google play and all those sort of things
so people can find you have American DVD
versions of it like is it it no there's
no DVDs here yet there's no American
version David days we have with anyone
like things that people don't need to
hear about but it turns out that I was
the only person in Australia who didn't
benefit from netflix coming to Australia
because my deal I'm a DVD at home has an
Australia specific deal and I own the
rights everywhere else in the world but
american netflix only want to buy things
they can play in Australia and in
America of course like for netflix and
why would they buy the rights to my show
in America or a place where no one knows
me and not get the rights in the one
place where it would actually mean lots
of people watch that I know please it
turns out they weren't that keen on that
will be going forward in a different
direction I guess stay chained in the
meantime steal haha well that's cool
well hopefully have you ever get any USA
versions will sell them here what's on
this side yeah right i mean time will
was fired as business manager yeah you
know what the worst thing is i'll tell
it is a little cautionary tale i did my
last spit film special because i do a
brand new show every year so like this
year was my 20th different hour-long
show and I and but I don't film them all
I have recordings of them all but you
know I tended to like it to be a live
experience and bug because my show is so
different from night to night the idea
of capturing like one night and it being
the night was never something a
particularly appealed to me and the
other thing is that I filmed one in 2009
which was the first part of this
two-part deal right that I had with
universal Who am I like in a DVD company
right and I didn't really enjoy the
experience so I just didn't make another
one and then it got to like you know
2015 and something like oh you know what
I want to make another special like I'm
ready and I want to like film something
and I love this show and like you know
it'll be the last night so you know it's
a good capture of that and all those
sort of things and but in that time like
you know I have a DVD deal dvds
basically don't exist any like you know
if the time has taken me to get to the
second part of the deal the technology
has pretty much died out so just a tip
if you have a too bad deal see if you
think the technology be around when you
want to do the second part of the deal
yeah yeah that would be mine I'm still
locked into a nine-part so negraph deal
yeah and that's not even recording to
that launches on myspace big myspace
lines [ __ ] you wait long enough the
technology comes back right retro yeah
yeah exactly I got a lot of cassatt
types of my friends elbows on this site
um that's why we don't have a pool yes
um we're selling outdated technology
yeah we just got Dana Gould Zell pisan
literally literally we're just not agree
i know we have data khalil beans for the
collectors so uh next week we're doing
the show on CB radio channel 46 check
that out breaker breaker hashtag work it
everyone in the parking lot i'll be able
to hear it what's i see more people yeah
all right well let's do it let's talk
about terminator genisys cuz i got a lot
to say but we're gonna do a spoiler up
on it we oak fantastic if this show
wraps up soon enough so i can go to a
show because my flight was like yeah all
right well if the guest was rustic way
ok well here's what i was saying firstly
that i enjoyed about this film i enjoyed
the fact that last time I came here we
talked about pacific rim and my main
complain about that film was that they
had to australian put two people playing
australians who weren't australians
right so i like this feels like a
balancing the force because the two
leads in this film are both Australians
right ah like John Connor and Kyle
what's his face Reese racing at sent
back so they're both Australian actors
and I there was points in this movie I
was like why didn't they just get some
Americans Jason Jason Clark is an
Australian actor yeah I didn't know that
man he's amazing right he is good but
he's and this is a totally not to so
this is not spoilery and I won't spoil
it but he also plays a certain type of
person and everything that he plays yes
and when you seem on-screen in this film
there is a twist in this that I won't
reveal obviously in this part of it but
I think most people will see coming
anyway but it does where you go couldn't
they've got a guy who is more
sympathetic like you know sometimes
actors just announced themselves and you
go ah yeah yeah yeah this isn't gonna
all go smoothly yeah yeah i mean he he
he really kind of came on the scene in
the zero dark thirty as the the like one
of the CIA interrogators he was really
good in that is really good as he has
that sceneries like you know he's very
calmly telling the guys that he's about
to torture like for information I'm not
your friend it's gonna get really ugly
for you and he's saying it like while
he's eating ice cream or whatever he was
in the Planet of the Apes reboot the
race of yeah oh yeah yeah um you know
and that was sort of his scared
scientist version right and he also had
the thing about an actor like that today
he also has a certain look even like
when it's he's passively on screen it's
almost like some of these actors like
michael shannon and paul dano they exude
a type of personality and character
without ever acting or saying anything
and sometimes if the characters against
that type that you see it's harder to
dig out of that hole sometimes right
like but it you know a good actor can do
it but you know you're not going to see
Michael Shannon is some sympathetic
character that's not creepy ever oh yeah
so they did there was two guys to join
jai courtney and and Jason and and of
course Sam Worthington was in the
previous one and I know there is a part
of me because i love the terminator idea
i'm a big fan of the to the first two
films i think a fantastic yes and in
fact on fourth of july they're playing
terminate
to again you know for America and we're
celebrating that were the leaders of the
cause of Skynet killing yeah humanity
sure and but I we were watching it and
it still just stands up i think is a
really silly like you know it's a great
yo film it's really well paced like you
know the action scenes are really
well-constructed and put together and
you know it has a real sort of momentum
and pace and you know dynamic to it
doesn't really think we're supposed to
do right really yeah and and it kind of
builds on it a bit and the idea is a
better idea like as you like the concept
of terminator 2 right like it just takes
it they understand that idea a little
bit more and they fully explore it and
then after that it's just obviously got
messy for me right like I just I haven't
really like enjoyed I'd like I've
enjoyed bits and pieces of the other
ones hmm well you also have the original
filmmaker James Cameron doing the first
two rights like you know I think in part
why the new band max was so good because
it was George Miller just gonna say that
because like that's that's the bridge
anova the original vision with with rise
of the machines and then salvation you
just didn't how many of their been again
there's but they all just blend together
so yeah if this is the fifth one so you
have terminator terminator to terminate
three rise the Machine salvation and
then Genesis which is which is one with
the girl terminator I think that's rise
of the machine yeah yeah that's three
Nick that's the next all one well it's
we it's interesting that none of us can
kind of remember exact because there are
those out late because the filmmakers in
this one have also decided to ignore the
plot of those ones yeah yeah because it
is a very referential film to the first
two films right yes like they're
basically the first half of the movie is
almost the scene by scene like it was
like one of those you know the gus van
sant remake of psycho like it was
basically what's his name med interval
it's born was right yeah and you can see
an hashes butthole i believe Oh Kevin
Smith the Kevin Smith bot told me that I
spoke
but no but it's it it's kind of and it's
kind of cool you could to see like you
know the original terminator and they've
got the technology and like Arnie going
back and you know all this sort of stuff
year's stuff that people have kind of
seen in the previous and stuff and it's
just set up and I kind of enjoyed that
but all that really made me wish for for
the rest of the film was that oh I wish
I was watching one or two right or I
wish that the person who's made one or
two Brad made the rest of this film
right because basically that someone
who's done a really good matchup of the
first two films in the first half of the
film but you know sometimes someone can
be a good DJ and do a good mash up but
you don't want to hear their solo album
JJ men and the second factor in songs
and the second half like a really good
cover band but like 180 this is our
first track of original oh yeah nonono
oh you know what do and wanted dinner
alive yeah what you who are the guys are
steel panther yes essentially the second
ravi's like when steel panther does one
of their own songs yeah like I takes off
his wig and goes this is who I really am
you don't know put the [ __ ] spandex
back on and turn on the road the the I
love that guy with the long hair within
plays that has the fan that blows his
hair yeah I don't know I don't want to
hear his real story right you know so I
thought that um I thought I didn't mind
the first like oh I hated ok so you
don't we don't need to see Judgment Day
again and we don't need to see like I
think this spending too much time that
all that stuff at the start we're in the
future and John Connors making the
speech to you like you're basically
you've just launched into a terribly
confusing barrel scene like and like a
speech by somebody that we have not got
to know and have not like you know
having well you know we know it's John
Connor but are you don't assume that
everybody is up to date because then you
spend half of a movie telling everyone
they're not up to date and here's all
this other stuff and so I thought it
started badly but then I kind of felt
like I felt like the like the third
after that when it was kind of
revisiting all that old stuff I kept
going oh this could be this could be
okay this is like taking the source
material and seems to have like me you
know I I didn't have as much of a
problem with the alternative reality
thing as some people did like some
people immediately like well we don't
want to see an alternative sure reality
and I kind of get that but I have a
podcast that's in your alternative
really so I'm not the person to talk and
I mean like both up is really terminator
genisys to Topher so I didn't mind that
aspect of it and I thought it gave them
like a you know a lot of potential to
kind of really change the story and
really kind of uh you know get back into
what the story was about and all that
stuff about you know because obviously I
Skynet is the is the cloud right Scott
it or Genesis like it is the cloud right
and we're in that right now so they're
trying to put yeah exactly data and and
and I and I if you were to tell me from
going into this without seeing a trailer
that there that's what they're gonna
kind of do is there's because when the
first movie came out 30 years ago there
wasn't a cloud was an iphone there
wasn't an Internet really so now we have
these things and there was this
opportunity albeit a very missed
opportunity for them to go hey now you
see where this could go the cloud has
all of our information all of it they're
tapped in all this thing right you know
and and they could do something
interesting of like so these cyber
attacks that we keep happening so like
the North Korea one right that happened
in last year just / supposedly is to
prevent the movie I know unfortunately
failed and failed but a lot of people
think it could have been disgruntled
Sony employees you try to make it look
like North Korea sure you could have
done something really interesting to go
oh that was when skynet was just filled
sewing and feeling it's like it's
testing its power and you could have
been like oh god that's so creepy and
you'd get this feeling and the feel like
oh [ __ ] we're living it and instead they
just kind of ganging like it was likely
I like some CIA office that starts
noticing all this extra activity like
spikes and stuff every every second
episode of person of interest has a
better like pot about this topic
Wow I'll tell you because there's so
much good stuff to work within that
feels very very true and will hits like
a really interesting point about this
movie it really set up a lot of good
intentions like you really could see
this movie wanted to be like what we're
going to reboot the franchise but we're
going to be referential to the other
movies we're going to have Arnold
Schwarzenegger so we're going to not
only tell you a new story we're going to
tap into the nostalgia and then we're
going to put a new modern twist on the
whole mythology that was the intention
and it it missed the mark on every count
because I wanted to really like it I
wanted to like Schwarzenegger and I
wanted to like I was excited about that
till the young Schwarzenegger a new one
right I was like oh let's see how they
do this yeah and even just like I I
guess everyone was looking for doing the
explanation of why is he old and I
thought I kind yeah yeah yeah that was
handled okay here's here's the analogy I
will make its if this movie is if Mad
Max was not done by the genius who
created it right but by a guy that does
a lot of TV Allen [ __ ] whoever your
name is Alan Taylor game of Game of
Thrones he did the seconds little film
yeah yeah he did it's all it's all TV
now grant granted really good TV show
right Boardwalk Empire a nurse jackie
madmen I mean Sopranos these are really
good shows but he but that doesn't mean
you can direct a terminator movie
there's still at this good I mean you
honestly because here's the thing and
this is this is why like is it it was
George Miller's crazy version him going
well now 30 years later we have all this
stuff imagine if Cameron would have done
this movie and said right this is the
movie that was kind of what turn white
Terminator 2 was so great he goes well
now we have a budget right and this is a
movie I wanted to make 30 years ago
something like that or now I in the last
30 years seeing just in the last 15
years seeing technology do this these
are all these things i wanted to add to
this story absolutely and he also like I
mean literally it the world has become
more like the world that Terminator was
parroting or like warning us about or
like whatever it
and yet they incorporated less of that
into the story right also what you say
about like you know not having a vision
for things and again this is not
spoilery there is a time-travel leap in
like the second half of the film where
suddenly a bunch of people from out of
time are in this new time a time that is
not familiar to any of them right and
they do not do one thing with that one
of the great things about Terminator 2
is that yo sort of he's a person at like
you know that yeah I'm swastikas
terminators trying to learn to be a
person it's a fish out of water thing
and this this movie just bounces from
one action set piece to the next action
set piece and you just get the thought
in turn off or an elk you like you're in
a time traveler film and you're having a
fight in your office block the one thing
that will look exactly the same look
most desire yeah yeah i feel like and i
just changed the computer monitors I
want because the director Alan Taylor
like has done so much good stuff I
wonder how much of this is like was it
his fault or was it like the studio
dangled feature film in front of him and
then sort of made him half well he could
only direct the script that he got in
the main problem with this is by far the
script yeah and alta to yet terribly and
it's it's one of those things that tried
to serve so many different masters that
it ended up serving no one you know you
want to be retro you want to be new you
want to be a mash-up you want to be you
know referential to the old movies that
but you're right though it was only the
first two movies that it was referential
two and it was also some weird casting
to like if you I you know I don't want
to give anything away we'll get into it
more but I was hoping at one point there
would have been a terminator doctor who
cross over yeah like okay now it's
getting a little interesting yeah I did
I thought the casting was I mean I like
the girl who's the lead in it in game of
she's a game with roads high school in
Game of Thrones but but if you hadn't
seen game of neurons and she was
spouting this ridiculous dopey dialogue
you would think gosh this actress is
horrible and like well she's not she had
literally nothing to work where I was
our problems do is like if you're gonna
bring that with me I don't watch Game of
Thrones yeah one of the most iconic like
like I mean Linda Hamilton's Sarah
Connor is like just stunning like right
honey that's I mean that's your fury
ossa from Mad Max and that's to end the
arc right of her from one to two where
she's just a scared waitress I was like
what the [ __ ] and then a mental ward in
a second right yes cuz she's like this
is hard and is like you know survival is
you can ever be yeah right and then so
that's already hard to like go to step
into those shoes right but then to have
that person say several of the like
lines and stuff that you like I'm never
getting a direct comparison yes is that
person saying those but like and I yeah
she I mean it felt like she was way too
young for it even though I know sit in a
time where she was younger but you know
with this story and you shouldn't have
the gravitas of like oh Linda Hamilton
and also was the way the characters were
developed there was nothing there was
literally nothing there I mean there's
nothing to hang your hat on at the end
except just one action piece don't even
like Schwarzenegger like granite he's
the Terminator you don't expect it you
know a lot of range but it was almost a
parody while i was doing his stuff felt
like that yeah I felt to comic yes you
know too much and why didn't they
develop if they could have there's so
much room here so they explained the Oh
why he's gotten old but couldn't they
explain Oh his you know his central
processing unit or whatever has adapted
and now he's more human-like or some
like some kind of upgrade or something
well weirdly enough and in this you know
we're probably getting some more of
those in the spoiler episode but like
they set up a lot of interesting things
like that but there are a lot of games
in the film where you go like I mean
there's another one where yeah this is
not so Sarah Connor has an awareness of
the story of the oh yeah like so she has
some knowledge and there's a central
storyline I won't give too much away but
the digital story line where it could be
changed because she has too much
awareness of what was going to happen to
her future and this is touch into this
really interesting area of like ah yo do
you still do that thing I have any
excitement for that thing if you know
that it's your pre-ordained sort of
and are you faded too no matter what you
do this is gonna happen again well this
is interesting yes yeah you go as an S
as actors and like on a right you know
just some stuff there that they could
have really got them to work with even
like the fact that you get come with me
if you want to live well that's yeah
well let's get into the specifics in the
spoiler ever because I don't we don't
want to but I really we are all
disappoint us together yeah yeah and
this I really think this movie was a
missed opportunity and it's interesting
it's like whoa I'm sure we'll get thick
embarrassed why did you like Jurassic
world and not this one sure and again it
was Anna for the record I didn't the
answer me well no you're Arya we add
some you were one of the people that
split absolutely still Saunders to let
me ask you this then so why why did you
not like Jurassic and then like you did
you like Mad Max oh yeah I love that max
okay yeah explain explain why these fall
on different sides of the fence for you
okay so i mean i'll do a really quick
explanation and if they want to hear me
bang on about every single scene in the
movie why every single on one of them's
almost wrong i would do that but here's
the thing the dinosaurs are great it's
like the same thing with the
Transformers movies i have this exact
same thing I say every time one less
transformer one less dinosaur spend that
exact same money on a decent writer and
you still make you just make a great
film instead of like my thing with
dressy everyone we go dinosaurs were
great in Jurassic world you know it's
just that I'm like literally name any
movie that is out at the moment and put
those dinosaurs in it and it is a better
movie than Jurassic world lately I think
you're seriously take any movie that's
out of the cinema and instead of what
they put it between the dinosaurs in
Jurassic we'll put that in between is a
bit that's true if you had terminators
vs dinosaurs i would i would have been
on board or more but me ill the dying
girl in the darkness all yeah that's a
better and that's an emotional reaction
because like what happens is like with
jurassic world like I said I because I
was emotionally had a reaction to I'm
enjoying this you forego and overlook
all of the obvious plot holes and
problems with the movie now with
Terminator I had the opposite reaction I
was like you know I kind of want to like
it ooh
I don't and now I'm gonna reject
everything even more because it's
getting dumber and dumber devil tonight
I'll tell you my emotional reaction is
that I've now wasted two hours yeah now
I'll tell you what it is for me I have
absolutely no problem with a movie being
as ridiculous as it wants to be like a
friend of mine had a real problem with
the guitarist on the front of sure thing
in bed max and i was like no no no cuz
to meet yet yeah that's crazy yeah but
in this world that they've created so
perfect in this context makes it makes
perfect sense we don't need to know why
the guys are spraying their mouth maybe
it's like yeah because their leader
where's the silver thing maybe it's
about how a myth much they don't need to
tell us because they've established
enough of this world that logically
makes sense they worship automobiles
they're separated into these things
everything in this movie makes sense
within the world that we have
constructed you can add your own
backstory like where I added like a
career path for the drummer's that you
know the best one my friend drama
eventually gets to be the guitarist in
the truck right but I mean that's us
like I mean you guys would be doing the
podcast about the you know you'd be
doing your skill right yeah and you'd be
up the front wis yeah but I can't wait
for the apocalypse I my problem comes in
movies where they set up things like
within their world and then completely
that they make then no logic to the
world I'll give you two quick examples
you're going to see prometheus right
yeah that's a good example but i'll give
you the examples of the two movies at
your own agent jurassic world and the
Terminator film now there i won't give a
spoiler on this but there's a scene at
the end of the like basically the way
this film like finishes completely
negates logically a in the universe
they've set up anything that's happened
like that just annoys me because I'm
like will you set up in the Terminator
right yeah in a terminator movie there
is a scene in jurassic world which is
the big famous scene where that though
the reveal of the Raptors right yeah
they reveal what they reveal that the
the other big asaurus the obama
disturbed ominous red eye darkness Rex
right whatever he is they reveal you
know I it because he can communicate
with the the Raptors cuz Chris Pratt's
trained the Raptors he's the right
Raptors alpha by the way that
never haven't yet they're the villains
of the it's like it's like Cesar
Millan's come in and train the Nazis I
know they're good now ah ed Hitler and
everything is fine so I that's already
so stupid like such a stupid premise and
he can barely contain them even the
person who's raised them from birth like
it's like I'm their alpha I can control
them the whole time Vincent D'Onofrio I
was like we should weaponize this
completely unreliable technology
weaponize it but then there's that scene
and they get to the dinosaur and then
suddenly they stopped and it's a really
cool yeah it's one of the coolest scenes
in the film right and suddenly hang on
what's going on like they were charging
towards it and now they're communicating
and then up in the like you the booth is
that revelation now like oh my god and
what's in there and then finally that
their job they put raptor in there and
like you know now it's communicating
with them I'm like literally 40 minutes
ago you told me in this film that this
dinosaur had been raised in it you like
without ever meeting another dinosaur
crisp at makes a point of it early in
the movie going one of the problems with
this dinosaur is it's never communicated
with any other than sauce it doesn't
know how that's literally you say that
in your film and now 40 minutes later
you can just talk because it has wrapped
up blood in it like if someone put
Raptor transfusion in me I couldn't talk
to a raptor it doesn't work like that
like i was born in australia but if i
was raised in a jungle i wouldn't go to
walk out into the street after 20 years
and go get a my heir ah doesn't work
like that like in the universe you set
up it does not work like that oh [ __ ]
that's awesome makes me want to see
Jurassic world again so now you know
there was a there was a lot of time
though then add ominous rex was not on
screen he could have been listening
grapes types yeah good point oh that
time he wasn't using his camouflage
right it was like
that familiar that he probably would
have used all the time but yeah yeah
whatever once yeah two pranked the
people i think he got some raptor
rosetta stones exactly and i think he
was studying in his off time yep on the
flight it makes sense makes sense to me
well paid a long was flying him some
types awesome i love these I love these
blockbuster debates well let's get
actually get into one of the movies that
as will mention would be good with the
dinosaurs in it which is me Earl and the
dying girl and Raptors with ceramic just
yet so all right if to those of you
listening to those of you who are like
alright all of this I don't give a [ __ ]
about dinosaurs or terminator and you
know I'm a little done with the
blockbusters they kind of have played
out for me this summer go see me Earl
and the dying girl it is uh it has none
of these things we've talked about there
is no alternate timelines it is just
it's the it's written it's it's based on
a jessie andrews book who actually does
the screenplay as well and it's directed
by alfonso gomez-rejon so it's really
good solid young actors await an actual
writer wrote the script an actual writer
wrote the script and now here's it
here's here's um here's an example that
now this director has done a lot of TV
he's done glee American Horror Story his
only other feature is this movie called
the town that dreaded sundown but this
movie I think first of all yet the
script is great because the this the
novelist did the screenplay right so
while adapting a novel is a specific
skill I think it's easier when the the
novelist does it obviously so so no
one's going to know it better no one's
going to know it know it better and its
really what's the basic premise is it um
here's the thing is that it's based on
this kid Greg uh you know who spends
this time he's the may I imagine yeah
he's been me
he placed me please me so he's the sort
of quirky kid you know and the movie
starts out and it's very cool he goes
you know there's all these different
worlds in my high school and I just AM
kind of friends with all of them you
know I'm friends with the jocks and the
weirdos and all this other stuff and
he's got this buddy of his who's Earl
and they make parodies of classic movies
uh in short films because he's got this
crazy I can't even go like all right so
he's got Nick Offerman plays as dad
Connie Brighton places mom Nick Nick
Offerman plays a tenured professor who's
never works he's always at home in his
pajamas eating weird esoteric you know
me academic food and watching classic
movie so he talked about his he was
watching like clockwork orange at like
age six I identified with this because
this kind of what my life was a little
bit um so they make these hilarious
parodies uh and there's really funny
moments in the movie and the movie early
on in the movie uh there's this girl who
has been diagnosed with cancer and his
moms like you need to go play with her
and be nice and beer friends ago I don't
want to I don't want to so he
begrudgingly does then of course they
strike up this this this friendship that
was their meat cute that was their meat
kinda want to meet the girl with cancer
yeah that's basically how it was um so
and and the mom of the girl with cancer
is played by Molly Shannon she does a
really amazing job of playing a single
mom who is trying to keep her [ __ ]
together while her daughter is battling
leukemia and the kid comes over and
Molly shands had a couple too many
drinks so it's sort of funny because
she's like oh you're she's flirty with
the team you know like doesn't cross the
line what walks up to it but obviously
the director did a great job this is not
this is a difficult thing to do with
somebody like Molly Shannon you come out
of the SNL world and it's big crazy
characters it's over the top but when
you dial them down to reality holy [ __ ]
is it great to watch I'm not saying
Molly Shannon wasn't funny when she did
a big funny characters but in a movie
like this you can't be over-the-top you
have to be route rooted in reality and
they do that and so the moments that are
funny are really funny and the moments
that are really touching and heartfelt
and sad are really strong and it's just
fun to that like you know this this
trend of like The Fault in your stars
type movies that those novels are being
made into movies they're being made
really well like this is another movie
coming out I saw the trailer for paper
town which is done by the same off of
the did fault your fault in our stars
Fault in Our Stars and you know this is
a really solid movie and it's got
hilariously especially fans of this show
it's got so many hilarious film jokes oh
cool the way they parody they parody
Seventh Seal and just like all this what
sounds like it was the perfect time to
release it to her it's bryce
counter-programming to every best of a
big you know ten poles and and i would
it's one of those movies like do you
have to see it in a big and the big
screen not necessarily but i would say
it's one of those like vote with your
dollar movies if you are tired of this
these big tentpole movies that are
making all this money this is a movie
you need to give and this is the tie I
don't think Hollywood's quite cut on a
hundred percent yet but this is the
perfect movie that should go on demand
along with a theatrical release so
people that want to see it I don't want
to deal with the multiplex but I want to
see something cool can just put it on
their TV and just yeah pay the 899 or
whatever or 90 and just watch it I well
when it comes out because this probably
won't do huge in now the actress not
going to do big theatrical numbers and
but you're absolutely right and a night
movie go and say the movie about the
bill don't look at me maybe I me me but
there's a lap dog girl depends on a girl
you like The Hunger Games and kids died
in that yes
yeah that's how you sell this as a
day-night movie this one just takes more
time yeah it's like a slow hunger gun
yeah just with just one kid yeah we're
fighting to advance yeah but this is
this is a really solid moving it's it's
it's it's the the the writing it's
exactly what we talked about it's
everything that Terminator Genisys
missed right uh is is it just has solid
writing solid characters really good
scenes the kid who plays Earl goddamn is
he funny um what's his name RJ Sylar he
has some hilarious just he has some of
the funniest lines in the end the whole
uh in the whole film he's just you know
he's tried as a dancing he plays this
like stone face kid and I it's it's a
funny solid movie cool check it out so
something for everyone at the multiplex
this weekend yes yes yes me and Earl and
diagnose move you need to search out and
find right because you want after you
watch it you're gonna really you're
gonna really glad you saw it so when you
know it's the one screen the terminators
not on at your movie theater we have I
got already seen terminator I it's plain
what six to eight it is oh there's 14
screens here oh but nine of them have
Terminator and five of them Magic Mike
and the i5 or Ted 2 and there's this you
know I have not seen Magic Mike XXL but
I am did an entire episode on my podcast
where I tried to guess the plot just
based on so having seen the preview so
here that if someone's seen it and they
can tell me what I got right or wrong
that'd be great but my big fear is this
is just from the previews from the Magic
Mike XXL previews is that it's done what
I like to call a mighty ducks to where
somewhere on the journey that will meet
some urban people who will teach them to
loosen up and shake up its it happens in
Mighty Ducks 2 when they're like like
the Ducks are playing for Team America
and then they go out and they find those
black kids playing street hockey yeah
and then they learn from them and then
the Ducks get there in their mojo back
and there's a big smell of a scene in
this those guys like
just can smell it from the trailer I may
be completely wrong I may be doing them
a disservice but I believe there will be
a saying whether the stripping troop
meet up some black strippers able let us
up and there might be a scene of them
working out maybe maybe my favorite
thing is i read that there's six
choreographed numbers in the in the film
which means that they have to find six
excuses to break into dance which is
always my favorite though oh yeah yeah I
always liked the what this oil be a
dance off of some kind yeah well maybe
won't I que ya me you are you trying to
tell me you think you could do that move
like Oh somebody yeah maybe there's a
West Side Story dance fight all right oh
I hope there's a dance fight um all
right well what what else do we want to
get in so we want to talk you know
you've been seeing a lot of the summer
movies will what what have you really
like so far this summer and what are you
looking forward I like Mad Max a lot um
that was you know probably the highlight
of everything that I saw would you think
of Avengers yeah look I do you know some
people really didn't like it um I
thought with everything that Joss Whedon
had to do like cuz that's you can't you
can't make a movie right anymore like
he's got so many things on the list of
what you have to get checked off in the
next two and half hours that I think I
think it'd almost be more impressive if
we if we saw like what he had to put in
at first because basically it's like
watching masterchef right and when you
get one of those challenges where they
give you eight any ingredients and
you're right everybody never do and the
thing is that some of those ingredients
are actually going to spoil like the
thing that you would make we'd like say
eight ingredients right but the
challenge is how do you best incorporate
yeah but you have to put in twelve to
put them all in yeah like that's the
game right and I feel like that's what
that movie was I felt like they were
introducing so many different things in
doing so many different bits of business
that he did I thought he actually did a
pretty good job of like pulling it all
together everything it in a sign it was
quite a balancing act for sure because
you know you've got the Mandate of you
got to introduce these new characters
you've got to service these new
characters you have to set up these
movies you know that are coming up with
like well how do I you know do all that
it
it's any I think he pulled it off I
really did yeah I those films are so
there's no I mean you they need their
own category and i don't mean superhero
category I mean the Marvel Universe
category where you have to like you say
there's a list of 30 we need this
character we need this storyline we need
this like you it the movie is so dense
oh and by the way you need to have just
amazing special effect fight action
sequences I mean bae their comic books
come to light and the way comic books
would always you know the Marvel
Universe in DC universe is like oh well
this character is guest starring in this
comic and now we have the Avengers but
then iron man and you know Captain
America they have their own books too so
and that's really what it is but that
wasn't easy to do and the other thing
what would happen is like this happened
with spider-man of the older comic book
recurs will remember is the characters
get over saturated you've got like a
spider-man book and then you've got 10
there's a second spider-man book and
then spider-man's guest starring in The
Avengers and then to really get the
whole story you have to buy everything
and that gets really tiring very best
Michael I just want to read one
spider-man book a month I don't need to
know what is going on in all these six
other books just to get this one story
so and I think the the danger is with
the marvel universe is don't spread out
too many branches you know stick to you
know what you've been doing ramp it up
slowly and don't make me have to see
these other four movies to understand
what's happening in this one yeah yeah
they keep it all relatable band and and
their other why I say all those movies
yeah and i watch all of agents of shield
so I'm like hahaha you know for it yeah
I'm on board yeah and there then i will
say that pit far they haven't fallen
into yet but i don't need to because DC
is gonna kick themselves into that
[ __ ] oh yes yeah they're already on
their way think this article about what
DC's doing with Wonder Woman I'm just
like yeah yeah they're making another
flash like they already have a flash on
TV then they're gonna be just great it
is great I like the TV show the flash a
flash and arrow were fantastic the flesh
is my I was always like I'd like that
right right I was like not one hundred
percent sold on it right
and but the flash like and all the stuff
that done with the crossovers in that
universe has made me like arrow more
absolutely gets better shows because of
the flash and that kid who's the lead in
the flash she's great and you know and
they do respect the right way his dad is
like the guy by the original flash TV
show and like it has a sense of history
but it does that really Hamill did the
same character the trickster again it
was really fun and did like it was just
the complete opposite to Gotham like
like exactly flash is really fun but and
it understood the source material right
and they do these great little easter
eggs to in the flash where they're at
Ferris Air Line you know Airlines and
they're like well what happened this
place is closed down what we lost they
lost a test pilot a while back and that
was you know Green Lantern right so and
then they there was like they show the
Suicide Squad and there's all these
little Easter eggs and it's fantastic
but the thing it's fascinating to me in
a very bad way is like you have the
successful character the flash you have
a successful TV show why in god's name
now would you start to develop another
flash I for the movie flash that's only
going to be in the Justice League move
it right what do they do top you're just
stop it make my sis got it yeah like the
way like agents of shield come are doing
arm is doing there's not a film version
hi yeah there's no pages of silk yeah
yeah yeah we'll see all of your movies
DC if you do it as good as marble I'll
see all the [ __ ] Marvel movies and
I'll see all the goddamn DC move and
here's a little secret you have great
characters to work with better
characters in my opinion it's not like
Bill Gates looked at Steve Jobs and went
well they're making computers we're
gonna make wooden boxes yeah let's make
computers worse yeah well yeah yeah
that's what we're gonna make them bigger
and less portable and how did you
understand yes lower
oh yeah on it what are you looking
forward to that's interesting I'm not
looking forward to the the Batman in the
Superman movie I just I I'm i don't care
i don't care i'm not actually i thought
i'd be you and i haven't talked about
this really well well well that's not
even the summer that's next summer well
yeah of course you've ever but first if
ya have a right to not look forward to
it but people who know my affinity with
those films which was i was showing the
other day on the TV and i watched like
that from start to finish like again
just like i do I start I didn't want to
I was like I was like literally like i
did not have nine hours and then I just
went you know you know well I don't know
I don't know what arguments you're about
to make but I just want to say that
whatever they are I agree with them yep
forward to either is funny you joked
about it uh i think it was pod fest two
years ago because the announcement it
just made about been hit like the joke
you made was everyone on the internet
was concerned that you and i right where
are we okay with that announce me Ben
Affleck is the least of my kin worries
with this new things uh what do you like
okay then I'm absolutely with you like
personally okay unless they tape over
the Christopher Nolan ones to make these
films just I'm fine yeah yeah like
they've nailed it yeah like they've
nailed Batman they guy first Lee why are
they making more Batman so quickly you
just nailed something just do a few
victory laps for a while Seinfeld didn't
jump into another shitty show straight
off the sign fell no you got to get into
Justice League that's a lap of honour
for five years right you know it's all
marketing it's like oh well this is hot
well then let's we gotta ruin it raha
this is this dis DC internally has I
don't know what's going on anyway
because they you know they've got all
these great comic book creators they're
just let them just like the TV they're
starting to do that like like arrow and
even flash there's there's comic book
writers on the staff but even then but I
don't know why Batman but then Gotham
Gotham is a disaster it had great
moments we both got you usually like
rain we got check out Gotham yeah yeah
exactly the Bruce Wayne the young Bruce
Wayne fantastic the Alfred I didn't know
he was some special op and that is
actually try that's for
macau that's on the comments and it's
great yeah that's great mmm and then all
the like it became a [ __ ] like like
some weird American Horror Story and
then like oh oh now every Batman villain
is a is the Joker a lazy psychic looks
like got a killer also now everyone or
he lives here already like Jimin like
yes alright so I want I want yo sorry I
was Batman Superman I was just gonna
break loose I on that topic though that
Jada Pinkett Smith is I believe in magic
my ex ex-l and my prediction for her
performance will be subtle magia her
next gonna move so I I mean I had a lot
of problems with the the first Superman
film it yes we are yeah a lot of her
I've never seen anyone angrier than Mike
Schmidt about it but yes you know none
of us liked you did you are you didn't
say may immediately after I watched it
okay where I decided I had to go back
and watch it again immediately just
because I knew that I was going to talk
angrily about it to other people and I
wanted to make sure cuz I wasn't when I
was first watching it I wasn't paying
attention to the things I hated enough
to explain why i hated them to other
people but i know you is like I was like
I you know what I'm gonna need some
points to back this up yeah you'll get
another sixteen dollars but you'll hear
about it through bad word of mouth at
the moment I just have a general feeling
I hate it but by the end of these [ __ ]
they don't have I'm gonna have some very
specific points to make a wonderful nerd
rage and but then and zack snyder just
like to me they completely missed it and
he's completely mr. on a whole bunch of
things that i like to be honest i don't
always like he always gets like some
stuff right which is obviously why he
keeps getting gigs as though but i will
say going back i still like 300 yeah yes
yeah yes yeah and and seeing the set the
second one that he didn't direct like
the daily produced and it wasn't bad
yeah second one it was it was ridiculous
and fun and goofy but it was still good
but uh but yeah the rest of the stuff i
always feel like he takes pretty
source material and doesn't do any
particularly excellent job with a right
um and yeah so I just have like almost
checked out of it that's what I feel
like I this happened to me like I just
keep seeing people will reveal like when
they do revealed yet they'll just
revealed even the Suicide Squad Joker
you know when Jared Leto and Internet
burnt down and I was just like yeah yeah
not getting is excited I just don't feel
it's far enough away from the heath
ledger like imagine if after the jack
nicholson one like two years later they
just had another thing with a different
guy playing the joker in her right like
it just it's true soon yeah I think it's
funny I think I'm having I've had a
similar reaction i was reading
entertainment weekly and they had this
big batman superman thing in and I was
just like hmm i read a little thing
about Wonder Woman cuz I'm like no well
the movies already too crowded that's
what's hilarious and they're already
saying oh there might be cameos from
other super year like no no stop just
tell the one story that's all you have
to do it's funny like yeah we you don't
need to remake the entourage movie but
we superheroes exact Wonder Woman's just
cruising down the street needed to be
crowded with cameras that's it's like
bread and that's like a jock of that
yeah yeah so I feel the same way so
anytime I see something about it I just
go on I'm not I'm not like enraged I see
you know Ben Affleck and I'm not excited
about I'm not yet just don't care I
don't even know if I'm gonna go see it
like I guess I will you will I mean I'll
say the show but I'm just like how many
times I mean you know I bet you're me to
see it once and I'm gonna not be I don't
think I'm gonna come out of there like
you know what's interesting the more you
hated the greater the chances that
you'll see it again oh absolutely no no
no no III will have to say Jurassic
world again but I just can't yeah yeah I
I didn't say it in 3d the first time and
I do want to go and see dressy world in
three days so at least one of the things
in the movie is three-dimensional
we'll add or something yeah I don't know
I I wonder if they take that into
consideration the box-office analyst
you're like well we're going to get a
lot of extra money from hate watching
yeah yeah I jig or I'd like if they
actually came up with like cake do you
think I look the 3d glasses for the main
center me here they're like twenty
dollars but uh if you want 3d characters
you can get them it's just an extra we
actually shot those things haha they
just don't play well in China so but if
you want to see that version we will
show you I bucks right probably true
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not excited for
the yeah I'm I can't get up although
he's what I was saying what does it give
characters nuance don't they say that I
would love this is an interesting I've
never been a big star wars person I've
always kind of said that there's like
one and a half good Star Wars films
which is like Empire Strikes Back and
half of star wars and the rest of it I
can really just like you know take a
life and but I'm quite excited about the
new Star Wars I hope they've got me back
my oh good I was kind of like you know
what it kind of looks like this might be
fun yeah I'm that I am excited about me
too and uh yeah and like we said I don't
we may be yours talk about this but
we've talked to steal Saunders about
coming to Australia to watch it on
opening night yeah so I don't know if
you're gonna be in Australia cuz we want
to watch it at midnight what what the
windows are open december 18 and we want
to use your pool yeah yeah okay the way
it is chapin a little for the gas
behavior I mean it's killing me the
australian dollars not as young as it
was when i moved over here do I now live
in a much more expensive apartment i
have not moved we'll sell some thrilling
adventure hour economies on the road and
yeah well so i'm on the plane yeah yeah
well move some units but yeah we want is
we want to fly in and do that a December
eighteenth and then it and then after
the midnight screening do a mashup
podcast with steel and us Oh that'll be
great that's a spoiler app I mean it's a
good idea be around oh yeah and this is
the thing no one cares what my opinions
on any of these things are because I see
everything yeah like I will go and see
I'll go and see it I've see I saw all
the Star Wars feel like I said I've like
one and a half of them and I saw them
all
probably in the first week at the movies
when our like you know particularly all
the racing ones I yeah well I better
keep going I mean now hahaha alright
well let's move on no DVDs and woman in
gold yeah I like that with the one with
ryan reynolds run ryan reynolds and uh
and helen mirren good if you missed it
it's a good little film to check out you
know it's it's not it's not like a big
oscar-worthy right you know to a divorce
but it's a good film they have good
performances it's like I think he
covered that with it stars Ryan Reynolds
yeah he's surprisingly good in it like
that's the reason to see it yeah he
doesn't ruin it yeah I would know with
right with ryan reynolds if you ever
hear the word good it will have the word
surprisingly in front of haha well you
can affect Ryan Reynolds and Helen
Mirren to be no the missing sentence if
you will next movie is Maggie and this
is another Arnold Schwarzenegger movie
that indie film right where daughters
got the Stars got zombie designs and he
tries to save artists now there's a
review by Neil on the site he really
liked it so you can check that out and
it's a movie that i missed that i do i
definitely want to check out yeah i want
to see you too i heard a great interview
with him on uh on radio about why he did
this film and he's like it's time to
give back i've made all this money and I
want to start doing cool stuff like this
right and that's that's great so and the
next movie is 71 now that took a long
time to come out on DVD but this is the
one about these so we had a guest talk
about this movie it was about a soldier
i think in belfast trying to get through
hostile basically a house a city hostel
to him oh yeah um i think its northern
ireland a booby yeah so it's a young and
disoriented british soldier is
accidentally abandoned by his unit
following a riot in the deadly streets
of Belfast endeavouring 71 yeah yeah I
remember all this did look really
interesting and a very limited release
so this is a good chance to just catch
up on ya I want to see Maggie and 71 yep
and also now on the site we want to talk
about there's a couple new things in the
store obviously we have thrilling
adventure hour when we appreciate you
guys have been buying that non-stop but
we have Jackie k shins new comedy
special oh this will make an excellent
Horcrux is now available for digital
download from the site
it's it's ten bucks and you can just
download it from from us also we have
that wasn't a joke we actually have Dana
Gold's new lps we go for the collectors
we even got special boxes to ship them
so they will get to you in tackle I love
this trend of a vinyl coming back yep uh
and and all these comics are like that
I'm like the nextel my 2 i'm gonna do a
vinyl and they're cool because they're
all signed to so if you're a Dana Gould
fan and like a collector you get a nice
it's a really cool collector well the
other thing is you signed it right on
the record so it won't play so what good
sense what yeah what you can do find
though is that like there are some
people that don't want just to have like
something in their ipod or whatever like
you want like a physical copy and like a
and that's why I think those like albums
have come back because it's like it's a
cool white a physical copy and honest
conversation but it's like a cool thing
to hang up and I will say to there's
something about having a big LP cover
with a signature on it that looks really
cool yeah because it's bigger it's just
a showcase is a piece of art right is it
is like I mean album art was a thing yes
very stink thing and was one of the
reason because it was how you bought the
album back then a lot of times you'd go
into the record circle that's cool art
right and you that was some of the
reasons why you buy anything do so sold
so many hours i was i was in portland
just the last week and i bought our bar
and crazy guy the Steve Martin album
like you know I'm vinyl and it was just
like five dollars in the shop in
Portland but it's just then he's like oh
yeah I'm glad that I have that I like
I've heard that album million times I
probably won't even put it on but I kind
of like oh no I had a stack of old
comedy albums that are just like I love
just knowing I have them I don't even
have a record player but I like having
it I want to do a little fan feedback
yes film nerd in turn Daniel Stevens
who's also going to be helping doing a
lot of social media for LA pod fest
posted its article in the LA Times about
a exclusive test footage of Nick Cage
suiting up for Tim Burton's never made
super lives wow that was fascinating in
your guys comments we got a great
comment from Eric laying the death of
superman lives what happened documentary
comes out soon
4 vo Dien blue blu-ray release uh you
should try to get director Jon Schnepp
yes Josh that's a great idea Eric like
uh yeah no I know John Hawley mill yeah
absolutely i'm sure he would have a lot
to say I'll I'll tell you this footage
because I saw a trailer for it actually
at the Egyptian and her John's movie and
the footage the test footage of Nicolas
Cage in the suit and is this Superman it
looks like well here's someone who's
never seen or heard of Superman before
is making the movie it's really it's
absolutely fascinating how like what
would this have even looked like like
like some kind of weird like ralph
bakshi animated crazy you know version
of superman it's like insane like the
guy who did the room made a superman
exactly but had never heard a Superman
before yeah I'm excited well let's try
to get jhanas show that and then thank
you Eric that's a really cool suggestion
um coming out this week we have minions
now this movie I will definitely be
going to see my kids are extremely
excited about this film now haven't been
a big fan of the despicable Me movies
they are simply not that great
especially when Pixar's putting out
stuff like inside out it makes them look
even worse but minions is that kind of
thing where it's like that side
character it's like the Dominions of the
fries iya ya yeah pretty much pretty
much it it's yeah yeah it's it's like
the Penguins from Madagascar well
they're the oh this is there far more
interesting than anything else is going
on in ninety percent of this film so the
kids are really excited and I mean I
don't know how it's gonna be I will
definitely be seeing it but I'm not like
holding any hope that it's going to be
at all interesting having uh we speaking
of like somebody watching is it making
Superman without knowing anything about
Superman the other day at Universal
Studios I went on the minions ride yeah
without knowing anything about minions I
wouldn't recommend it yeah
I feel like you have to be at least
bought into the minions universal
probably under the age of 12 to fully
appreciate the meters right yeah for the
record kids love the ride as well and
they're under 12 no and did you go and
do you see the new Fast and Furious
right on the tram yes oh that's why
that's why we win was you're the fastest
yeah that's why we win the past and feel
like I've got the new Fast and Furious
thing is it's on the [ __ ] yeah part of
the tram ride yeah it's weird though
that late and it's it's too much like
it's too much like it's one of those
things where you like even by the
standards of it but the it's somehow
they've made them worse actors like
they're like somehow animating them and
getting them to record something it like
it it's worse than it is in the films
but clearly it's like was it a rider and
I think I'm gonna you know normally I
phone in a performance for the film Russ
is a ride I'll go yeah but my favourite
bit is not the acting by the like a you
know it would buy that all the
characters from Fast and Furious but
what you get to experience when you go
on the tram ride which is there's a set
up to it Oh Larry yeah so so suddenly as
you're going up to because the King Kong
ones great but you basically just go in
there and then suddenly you're in the
King Kong world and you're it like yet
but the experience is happening right
yeah they're there is a setup and
there's like different areas there's
like the first like the first the pre
story I was like the story then you
actually go to the actual rice i like
about at one stage yet spoilers spoilers
for the tram ride but at one stage ii go
fast like a car like you know fast if
your style car that's like and and that
your tram drivers like hang on that's it
was to piss harvest I'm supposed to be
on to the block and then they started
doing like a walkie talkie like you know
through to like and then like people
buzzed into your tram to say that yes I
like it that that bits great i love I
that's my favorite thing they always
start out is like well everything's
going fine whoa wait oh just down and I
we'll say that the technology in this
ride is unbelievable right like when
you're in it you're in a [ __ ] you're
gonna Tramon literally you're speeding
down the freeway with you people
shooting at you right and it makes you
why that's why most people at la are
going just right idea that I could sit
down like it's not not done with the
Miller died and the freeway is empty
it's a fantasy fantasy yeah yeah it's
like the 405 the middle of the night or
right before the president gets there so
but you they do something like like they
have fans inside the ride so you get
that rush of air like you're going
really fast and you know that moves so
you like you really like you hang on
like you're actually moving like your
brain actually gets fooled into thinking
you're on a high-speed pursuit but
really cool so it's like because the
Transformers does a lot of that too and
that ride but that's I mean I those the
Transformers ride better than any of the
Transformers movies buy a house yeah
yeah like if the transformers is a good
ride but they should do is write those
rides I make the ride longer make it
look at an extra bit that you just go
and line up for the next video right
make the rides longer in the movie
shorter right all right speaking of
great movies coming out Ryan Reynolds
has a great one selfless this is a body
so up / less yes a good body swap movie
it's like it's it's every one of these
cliches stories played out it doesn't
look good to me new and others oh let it
go get woman in gold yeah it really if
you're really on a rail revs kick and
you need a little taste hmm go get that
or wine and then you'll be full or find
two guys a girl and a pizza place yeah
he was good at that yeah I tested for
that show so I was one of the last girl
was really good great oh yeah there's a
movie it was saying that movie worries
in the coffin the whole time a coffin
taffeta married very very good anyway
Ryan Reynolds Barry babe um so anyway
the last movie is Boulevard this is
actually a Robin Williams film so it's
it's about him as a family guy who
actually you know develops like a secret
life I saw the trailer it looks okay but
that always happens when the star passes
I all of these movies slowly come out
like the next you know year or so
afterwards so and every one of them this
says this the last movie may but wait
this one just says you know they always
use that as a marketing hook
unfortunately but I don't know if this
one's any good I saw the trailer and I
don't know so but you know it is good to
see Robin Williams obviously on on
screen one last time so okay that's it
guys put 276 in the books will anderson
where can people find you on the world
wide web and the like and yeah i wil
with 1l underscore anderson on twitter i
have a podcast Toph optio fop it will be
at the La podcast festival yeah well and
which we're looking forward to very much
Charlie my co-host who yo Mike hey
general co-hosts in the old universe is
he flying out again he's flying out
again so yeah it was really huge last
year we had such a great time so we're
looking forward to doing that again it
does this come out tonight yeah cool so
I'm this week I got some gigs around la
of people around our lamb John meltdown
on Wednesday and I've got a set list on
friday nite at The Improv which will be
really cool fun but saturday night at
seven o'clock at the nerdmelt theater
i'm doing my our motoring show that I do
around the world free will which the
only time i'm doing the the whole hour
here in LA Gareth Reynolds is doing
support for that and then I mean very
nice well for that look it's a wonder it
is not but there will be you know it's
what they are I always said there's like
20 on the night so a poor one but it's
kind of booked out but they do do will
be I mean basically if you come down
we'll find a way to squeeze you and so
that should be really cool our next week
i'm at comedy on state in wisconsin it's
a great club I hear nothing but great
things you're gonna love that club and
will play the Hanson brothers will show
up and say hello Oh that'll be good and
then Toronto for a couple nights and
then Montreal for just for laughs so
yeah you can but you know find all those
dates in those places you know in the
appropriate places and my DVD will
luminaries available purchase some
places and if you can't purchases away
you are steal it is it on itunes it's
only at not here not your legends genus
oh you know what you can do if you if
you if you wanted like legitimately by
and you're in
the u.s. if you've got a friend in
Australia get them to send you an itunes
card if you got an australian itunes
card you can just go in and buy it off
the itunes and download and watch it on
that when i have to set up an account
you just need a you know like a gift let
us know when it does come to iTunes here
in the States because we have a CFN
itunes store oh yes you know that's
fantastic and we can we can put it in
there absolutely yeah cool brilliant
awesome well guys uh that's our show I
will be headlining the improv Tara's
Hotel and Casino in Las Vegas Nevada
next week July 14 through the 19th and a
couple other things going on what else
we got go on and I'm in lake tahoe in
august that is tahoe is august 19
through the 23rd and also headlining the
hollywood improv August twenty-ninth so
come check that out and of course Los
Angeles podcast festival September 18
through the 20 absolutely uh the week
after i'll actually be in tahoe yeah
i'll be there you're going to tahoe and
we've just added jen kirkman is now
doing pod fest yes lauren lapkus is
doing it we've got about 20 some shows
confirmed the Sklar brothers Todd glass
Janet Varney stuff you should know yeah
obviously Marc Maron Aisha Tyler Lee
ventured adventure hour through first
time thrilling adventure I were doing
the fest or first time uh Doug Benson
doing Doug loves movies and dining with
Doug and Karen Todd glass we've just
been working on some other stuff with
the festival that we're going to be
announcing soon but the we're also
updating the website for sure and what
we want to mention to we've got some
gaming podcast we haven't before this is
new work we're adding giant bombcast is
confirmed and also indoor kids yeah this
is cool first time ever having endure
endure kids I believe right we have one
we think we Adam once done before but
first time for giant bombcast yeah so a
lot of first time shows and of course
Kevin Avery and w commonwealth denzel
washington is the greatest actor of all
time period they're gonna be there so
we're gonna have at least you know some
some classic favorites and a lot of new
shows yes we're going to be awesome and
we're going to do a little preview night
on the seventeenth that's the yeah
improv at the improv sideshow network is
helping us with that so here's
how that's going to work guys will
announce more details as it gets closer
but if you buy a weekend pass you can go
to these these the preview night on
Thursday the seventeenth at the
hollywood improv using your weekend pass
we'll have you can go get your weekend
passed away thursday early yeah at the
improv so it's a little bonus if you fly
in from out of town or you there's gonna
be about four to eight shows at the
improv because we got the whole place
we've got the lab upstairs and we've got
the main show yeah we've got the whole
the whole place so it's a little cool
thing if you're in town and night early
or you live in LA and you want to buy a
weekend pass it's just an extra night of
shows you're gonna get right so it's
gonna be really how can you go wrong how
can you go wrong I also want to give a
big shout-out you know to the pod
podcast community one of our fans
Alyssa's the show a lot Ashley raper was
going through a tough time and many of
you rallied and showed support for
showed support for her on Twitter many
of you emailed me directly like Vanessa
a couple others said hey Graham if you
talked to Ashley she okay she's doing a
lot better and that's just no Neal was
checking in on her yeah Neil was
checking in on her and just the fact
that you guys did that is just why this
medium is so awesome and you know like
every day you know we're watching
footage for ear buds yep and hearing all
about that is it's such a cool thing
that we've helped create this community
really your help you're helping someone
like you really help somebody in huge
ways so Ashley a big shout out to you I
know you traveling back to Michigan so
we'll talk to you soon so that's our
show ladies and gentlemen there will be
a terminator spoiler app coming out
later this week and uh go to all the
websites and like all the stuff and
you're following all this all we should
mention will be at comic-con this week
too yeah kung fu extravaganza a night
and Neil will be joining us this is his
first Comic Con all three of us will be
there so check it out if you're going to
san diego going to comic-con will be
there thursday night yeah we'll be
walking the floor Thursday day and I'm
gonna go to preview night too and
Wednesday night yeah because you have
the you have the show with Doug I'll be
on show there and and on Wednesday night
with Doug and then um yeah it'll be fun
man sikri great come on sit down ma'am
con alright guys that's our show Thank
You Will Anderson
thank you sorry I was just sitting back
no one needs me to make these plugs go
longer I'll just I'll sit back or I'll
stop plug another slider let us jump in
alright guys well that's our show my
name is Graham Elwood and I'm Chris
Mancini and it's always remember haha
first